[Music]
in interesting expense news so
interesting submitted by team Nike ooh
uh yeah
Nike New Balance ladida yeah I don't
know why it always have to be a team's
like so like separated and so cuz you
got a right pair hood that's why ya
can't be the [ __ ] belt - you mean
like Nike for food teams because you're
giving me that mom cuz I have something
in my mouth and I was thinking of food
like it is allegedly visited strip clubs
with co-workers and athletes on the
company's dime
hell yeah they should what's the problem
wait yeah yeah I feel like it got what
is News Journal reported that's it well
that's a tax write-off it's
entertainment yeah no no I mean like why
why is it alarming maybe I just wrong
where it's been happening for since
strip clubs came to existence
there's only business they probably were
the reason why secret strip clubs even
started because he would hire all these
hot girls and guys or whatever and then
they'd get him in a hotel suite yeah in
Japan they would just have a lady play
this really weird sound guitar and they
do a little [ __ ] jokey play and then
they will [ __ ] him after yeah under
armours like me to movement our moment
here now so like they're they're saying
that these practices were so women at
that company would find it very
demeaning they could come to know oh
well I mean that's I mean my personal
opinion I'm like guy who cares they're
strip clubs but the part that it's kind
of my stuff is the one that so they'll
invite female staffers based on how
attractive they are to certain events
hotspot da yeah that's the part wait how
do they know that cuz it could be really
sensitive people are just saying like
well I wasn't invited
and everything could be assuming these
things unless it said like hi [ __ ]
only yeah but they called it stocking
the pond like it's a event managers
would call that stocking the pond so
like only putting female so these would
be a young like lower-level like in the
company female staffers that would be
invited to these certain events of where
they it's like but everyone does that
yeah it's right or wrong but I get yeah
and that just makes me want to buy Under
Armour more like I feel like I had my
own company and I knew that I was like
trying to swoon a client and he really
liked like Latina woman but I wouldn't
go and bring all my Korean girlfriends
that worked with me like I would bring
you know I would just like I feel like
it's because it's in that setting where
you're like like networking and whatever
and you want to impress them by having
the best look that makes sense I was
looking at it in a way of like that
sucks man they're having a party and
they don't include the fat girls that's
[ __ ] up for me I'm like I don't care
what you look like we're all going to
the strip clubs and I'm buying all of
you lap dances cuz it's gonna be fun I
think that is what was happening your
first one is what's happening they're
not inviting the unattractive girls not
to see that the factors are unattractive
but they were they were just saying like
we're only picking the people we find
attractive
that's all those are the only ones that
can party that's dumb you should be
inviting that people who aren't
attractive because they they can't get
that attention there's some hot
proportional fat girls though but why
can't those women just go to the strip
club in their own group on the company's
time as well instead of joining their
party because they sound like losers any
yeah what's the what's the real problem
oh there's no women like oh what's the
problem oh that's being reported well
that they used to do that I guess a lot
of people will just find this appalling
that was yeah I mean it is kind of a go
to strip clubs and that they would
select certain females to come be only
based on their attractiveness that is
kind of it mean it's rude like let's say
like I was considered one of those girls
right and then I get invited to that I'd
be like whoa this is [ __ ] weird right
but what's the difference of meat right
now what's the difference then between
like let's say there's a JK skydiving
trip right and then you guys don't
invite me and David because you guys
know we're scared of heights but that's
different because we're doing you guys a
favor you're not valued by your looks in
this situation it's like it's like you
know as a crew work that we value each
other by each other's work ethic and
skill right and if we want to party
together we don't go based off of like
well you know you're not that hot yeah
now it feels like what the [ __ ] dude
like I contribute to this company I'm
one of the best team members and it's
like I'm not included because I'm not
cool or like I don't look good or I'm
not sexualized that's [ __ ] up oh
that's where it's kind of like that
sucks because they want to lab there's
even more [ __ ] up than it is on the
company dime so let's say it wasn't on
the company dime and it was yeah then
yeah then that guy's just a [ __ ]
prick yeah well I would never take it
with him off worked hours anyway but
because it's happening on work hours
that is [ __ ] up and just on the
receiving end to where if the person is
only getting getting invited because of
how they look that's [ __ ] up like not
everyone is wants to be treated just
based off how they look is this for the
company when they're dealing with
clients is just company we're dealing
with themselves see I get I get why do
you get both sides like I get why they
do it right because they're trying to
get the business they're trying to make
their client happy but at the expense of
people which is [ __ ] up yeah I see
that all I saw was client bring them
strip club that's all I saw that's what
I heard initially to and I'm like what's
the problem like if that's what they
prefer then let's go have a good time at
a strip club at a bar at a movie at a
[ __ ] whatever but now to do it that
way that is fun cuz mob the company my
mom worked for I don't know if they had
these practices anymore but it's like a
like a fortune 500 company like for even
on their sales requirement if you're not
attractive and not bilingual they won't
even hire on their sales team okay let
me but the don't write it so I worked
for a really high-end watch brand and
this was like maybe a couple years ago
in LA go Lex
likes it even higher than that what
about bubela it's probably a traffic
trollop we're shutting it down but there
was this guy who would spend millions of
dollars with us every single year like
this guy was loaded
what's his name I need a piss right
right older Middle Eastern guy he's
literally older than my dad and he would
do this thing he would come all the time
he would ask me to make his Nespresso
because he says I'm the only one that
makes it taste good Wow and he would
literally okay so it's a table like this
is a VIP table but it was like for my
instant coffee maker she's my buddy
that she makes it so different and you
[ __ ] go to the Keurig and you just
you I don't work for you [ __ ]
but you do though at these place at the
service place I was I would be like he
tips so good so essentially every time
he comes in he has like just he wears
two watches he's one of those guys who
were turning guys like that he genuinely
loves watching I wish I could wear to
watch so then we have security guards at
our location because watches right but
then he's like he has to be escorted to
valet from the store because he was just
shown like you know so then people might
be snooping he always requests that I
walk him down to valet I security [ __ ]
him I didn't injure your than just
killing exactly but he would literally
take pictures under the table of my legs
and like I knew this was happening he
wants to make sure that's Dylan's money
no he wouldn't even turn off the little
tune noise it's like he's up front about
it you wanted electronic yeah well you
kept the noise out so you know he's
making sure you're not stealing
it'll be like Oh God because he likes to
do this thing he brings vintage watches
they're all super fancy and then like he
likes to take pictures of them with like
the Miss breast so she's like really
basic right and then he'll email them to
the store email one of those emails had
just like shots of me on I told my
manager about it because I was like this
is on the story email do you see that
I'm getting sexually harassed but he
spends billions of dollars yeah
literally the regional manager flew from
up north to come and have lunch with me
to just kind of like talk me out of like
a lawsuit in [ __ ] [ __ ] sue the [ __ ]
out of them I would have no I couldn't
it's a long story I'll explain it after
you guys it's crazy you probably paid
you a lot of money no it's gonna be
mind-blowing afterwards yeah it's wild
but like but that's the thing though
right like a lot of people who are
[ __ ] ballin they can get away from the
they can get away there above oh yeah
yeah yeah they are like you know this is
not right in in in in general like
ethics like it's it it happens we all
know what happens we all but we don't
like that it happens but it does like
things like this right that's why it's
kind of normalized because we kind of
expect companies to go out and and
sexualize women and [ __ ] go and strip
clubs and whatever because money that's
the reason why it's like we want this
client this clients a [ __ ] perv let's
take them to the strip club let's have
fun but no ugly girls or like this guy
loves blondes let's bring all the
blondes let's bring all the Korean girls
or whatever that's what's happening here
and and that's when you try to mix
business with like regular people
ethics it doesn't really is hard it's
hard it's crazy because I actually
talked to an attorney about it and I was
like how can like such a big company
think that this is okay like do they not
have an HR team and they're explaining
that a lot of companies they'll
literally go out of their way to break
laws because like let's say false
advertising right they like distribute a
bunch of posters and it says like the
best watches in the world but that's
accurate but they'll get the fine
they'll pay the fine but people will
still remember that so it like they're
losing money but they're like gaining
something else so they're saying
whatever I want to sue them for is they
all know that attention any attention is
that product is in their head and that's
[ __ ] that's so sick like people don't
understand this but that's how chump
wins that's how a lot of people get
riled up and and they they are obsessed
with the Kardashians and [ __ ] like that
because Amy this is like next-level
marketing [ __ ] but like anything that
makes you feel something whether it's
positive or negative but usually
negative sticks with you more than
positive because then it triggers that
danger thing or that warning thing in
your head so if something pisses you off
you talk about it all day you can't stop
thinking about it all you're doing is
going around talking about politics and
how you're outraged they don't
understand that they're actually being
brainwashed when they think they're so
[ __ ] woke BAM mind blown yep isn't
that crazy and then you're spreading the
word everyone else is getting pissed off
about it too and then they can't stop
talking about it and that's how it keeps
staying in the media that's so true
because I always follow up on like
people I hate social media more than the
people that I like you know are okay
with yeah cuz you're obsessed like if I
hate a [ __ ] I'm like what are you doing
today you know really that's that's a
[ __ ] caddy girl thing though because
the people I hate I like people I hate
and they don't even know I blocked on my
unfollow them they're gone they're off
my rangers that's the crazy thing like
people I don't like I don't that time
they don't even know me but I blocked
them just in case II trying to look at
me that's how much I don't even come on
my site I don't even [ __ ] look you
don't even exist yeah they could be very
well might even like me as a person but
because I don't [ __ ] with them I blossom
like even people that run in your circle
like for like haters on the inner and I
just block them but like people that
like maybe your friends is friends with
but then you guys have like a weird [ __ ]
you still block I don't think I have it
no no I can't have weird [ __ ] with
people that I know in person or that's
too close to me I got a I got a have I
got a have like clear air cuz it makes
my life so stress and Plus please if
somebody if I do
like somebody told David about someone
in real life I'm just gonna fight them I
wanna I want a very stress-free life
yeah and I don't want to [ __ ] think
about how like where I stand with the
person or any of that [ __ ] it just and
it's better that way I don't want them
to think that we're friends because I
don't want them to have like yeah
expectations of me so how come you
didn't come to my wedding because I
[ __ ] hate you I told you to your face
you [ __ ] loser
what do you mean I don't like you yeah
[Music]
[Music]